each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so we have in this session we've got
three talks two of them are really in
the what we call our applications
tracked the third talk that was
originally scheduled was cancelled but
we were fortunate enough that we've got
a really great replacement and that is
will be the third talk and I'll
introduce it when the time comes up but
right now I would like to introduce
Magdalena ballads in sky and from the
University of Washington and she's going
to be talking about interactive
fault-tolerant data analytics in the
cloud Magdalena thank you thanks
everyone for coming so the fracture I
start I just want to say that this
project is part of a larger project in
the computer science department that you
called new ash which is the French word
for cloud the motivation for the new ash
project is pretty much add stock this
morning so I don't have to repeat it but
we're looking at it from a database
perspective we are database expert and
we're asking the question people in
sciences especially but also in other
domains have lots of data that they need
to process analyze where our current
tools failing and should we be building
new tools how can we improve existing
tools how can we help people get onto
the cloud so this is kind of the
high-level motivation for our project
this project is of course you know based
on hard work by the following great
graduate student and in particular
today's talk will focus on precise work
also in collaboration with young control
we also have several great faculty and
this is a action interdisciplinary team
with have partners also in astronomy &
bill how who's a computer scientist but
also has strong ties with oceanography
and other sciences so on this kind of
general nuage project we have several
goals overall we want to help people in
particular scientist with their data
management problems for this we have
projects that look at the simplifying
data management how can we help people
get over the hurdle of actually
accessing cloud-based systems how can
you help them just write simple queries
to access the database
if they go to the next step how can we
people express how can we help people
express complex analytics in system such
as MapReduce or parallel databases in a
way that resulted in efficient execution
and finally which is the focus of
today's talk how can we help people when
they do this type of large scale
analysis using MapReduce parallel
databases how can we help them get more
interactivity and also kind of still
preserve kind of large-scale scalability
and resilience and for this we have
tools that allow people to just observe
what is going on for example the primary
and progress estimation but also this is
kind of really the focus of today's talk
is the how can get both interactivity
pipelining and fault tolerance together
but I'm mentioning this quickly because
if you're you know this is the beginning
of the workshop if you'd like to talk
about any of these other topics that be
happy to talk about this offline so what
is the problem the problem is the
following I have some sort of
large-scale data analysis that i would
like to run using maybe map produced
using maybe a parallel database but i
would like to see results incrementally
i would like to see results directly as
this can be produced early on during the
execution of this long analysis because
i would like to have any insights
perhaps to cancel the job if the results
are not what i expect them to be at the
same time i would like to make sure that
the entire computation terminates and
finishes quickly and you might ask well
why is this a problem this is difficult
because it's actually difficult to have
both requirements at the same time
typically if i would like to see results
incrementally I want to just pipeline
data of through all my operators but if
I do this and a failure occurs somewhere
in my query plan I will have to restart
the query so that kind of my total time
to completion is going to be longer so
let me illustrate by showing what
today's tools are actually doing so
first what I could do is I could use
MapReduce and that produce takes the
approach of fault tolerance but without
interactivity so in this case as you all
know in a MapReduce system my data is
going to start on disk and to run my
analysis I'm going to first
the data from disk a habit process by a
set of map tasks that are going to then
right there intermediate data to disk
then I'll have a second step which is
the reduced step where all the reduced
tasks are going to read the data from
disk process it right it again to disk
and I can kind of continued by having
additional MapReduce jobs follow on with
subsequent computations at large scale
when failures occurred this is great
because if anything fails like if this
map task fails all I have to do is just
reprocess the data regenerate their
interviewed results and I'm done the
problem though is I see nothing I don't
see any results until all the data has
been processed because i have this
blocking mode of processing
alternatively what I could use is a
parallel database and here the strategy
is different the strategies to read the
data from disk and stream it through all
the different operators my query plan to
produce results if my operators allow me
to see results incrementally if those
are non blocking operators that I can
get early results as basically the first
deposit or getting processed so this is
great to have incremental processing to
see Ernie result but if something
crashes well I don't really have a
choice I have to restart my query which
is not good if I'm going to really try
to scale it so the question that we
asked in this product is can we do
better than these two extremes and the
answer is of course yes and the first
part of the solution is that actually
nothing prevents me from taking a
pipelined query plan and making it a
fault-tolerant in fact I can do this
using existing techniques from the
literature but the second question we
started to ask is well which strategy
should we be using and actually what we
concluded and this is really our
contribution is when I have this
large-scale query plan I can actually
mix and match and decide to perhaps have
no fault tolerance in one fragment of
the query plan make some other parts
fault tolerant and kind of do this
mixing and matching that you allow me to
get the fastest expected overall
completion time as an example of regs as
an example if I have a query plan with
thats a very simple stateless operator
perhaps it
not worth to do much because it is
operator crashes I can just kind of keep
going where I left off whereas if you
have a very complex aggregate operation
with lots of state well then perhaps
this is an operator that I would like to
check point so what we wanted to do in
this project is to enable kind of this
use of these different strategies inside
a single query plan and have an
automated way to figure out which
strategies to use so how can we
accomplish this well the first part is
that I would like to take a query plan
and have this ability to mix and match
the different strategies photon and
strategies so here's an example of a
very simple query plan with only three
operators or one or two or three what I
would like is for each of those
operators to be able to autonomously
decide what filter and strategy to use
perhaps using no strategy at all but if
something crashes I would like to
restart these operators individually I
don't want to have to restart the whole
query plan so for this we came up with a
protocol that actually very simple and
uses pretty known techniques from
homogeneous photons strategies so the
first rule in our protocol is that all
the tuples that are going to be
transmitted from one operator to the
next must have unique identifiers this
will allow us to kind of keep track of
the progress of different operators
second if an operator crashes it's
actually allowed to ask its upstream
neighbor the upstream operators if or
two crashes it's allowed to ask a one to
resend any subset of the data that it
produced earlier so this is for example
map produced this would be easy to
satisfy because a one would write its
data to disk so if or two asks for any
subset of it it can just read it from
disk and resent it if I don't have any
filter and strategies maybe this will be
more difficult to satisfy but maybe
still possible here we don't ask how we
just require that the operator be able
to do this for efficiency in many cases
we can actually have some guarantees
that an operator once it made sufficient
progress even if it crashes it won't ask
for a certain subset of totals so we add
the third rule that an operator can
optionally acknowledge the data that it
received
and if it does so it guarantees that
it's never going to ask for that data
again and I can allow the obscure
operator to to optimize what it's going
to do and finally we also ask each
operator to remember the last input data
item that it received such that if
something crashes restarts it can
basically ask its downstream neighbors
exactly where it crash for it left off
and were to continue processing from to
avoid any duplication so these are very
simple for rules and as you notice that
if now each operator can implement any
fault tolerance strategy that it wants
including doing nothing as long as it
can guarantee that it can satisfy these
four rules so how failure recovery works
well if an operator let's say 02 crashes
and restarts what it can do after
restarting is it can ask all the
downstream neighbors for the last double
they receive so it knows exactly where
it left off optionally if 02 saved any
state it can recover that state it
doesn't have to it can definitely ask or
want to resend any subset of the data
and with this it can simply continue
processing reprocess it and wait until
it reaches the point where it left off
and it can continue sending data without
duplication to its downstream neighbor
so as you can see now behind this
protocol I can implement different
strategies for example if or two is a
stateless filter operator perhaps I
don't need to do anything for fault
tolerance if it the operator crashes it
simply asks its downstream neighbor
where it left off doesn't need any state
and it can ask its upstream parents to
keep sending data exactly from the
corresponding point where it left off
and we can get something very efficient
in contrast you for example or two is
some drawing operator that accumulates
lots of state if that operator chose to
nothing and it crashes it would have to
restart and reprocess all the data from
the beginning in contrast if that 02
operator chose to check valid state then
it can recover that state from this can
only continue processing data from that
last checkpoint so this allows us to
kind of do this mixing and matching
the strategies that we do investigate in
our prototype include the strategy of
doing nothing which I described with the
example of the filter the strategy of
checkpointing the state which I just
described with the example of the
drawing and also the strategy of
materializing which is what MapReduce
does were here each operator simply
writes its own output to disk doing this
doesn't help the operator to recovery
itself but it helps when the downstream
operator crashes and asks for previous
data but the big question is that ok
this is great this all works I have to
be a little bit careful how I implement
these strategies to get efficiency but
that the question is well how do I
choose which strategy to use if I use
something like checkpointing i will have
maybe higher overhead potentially faster
recovery if I do nothing I will have
lower overhead but potentially slow
recovery how can I figure out which
strategy to use so for this we developed
what we call FG opt which is a false
torrents optimizer the input of this
optimizer is the query plan and also
information about the clusters such as
the amount of resources in the cluster
and the probability with which different
nodes can fail in the classroom the
output of the optimizer is the strategy
for each operator in the query plan if
an operator is going to check on its
state we also compute the checkpoint
frequency for that operator and
optionally we can have a resource
allocation because depending on how many
resources i allocate to different
operators then they have more slack or
more room to do extra fault tolerance so
how does the optimizer do this how does
it produce its output from this input so
for this is actually select the filter
and strategies resource allocation and
also checkpoint frequencies that
minimize the following objective
function so sure I didn't want to give
the formula because the intuition is
pretty simple what we want is minimized
the total run time for the query so we
we work with career plans in the form of
a tree and you look at the longest the
slowest part industry and we look at the
time to propagate the first topple or
data item all the way to the last
operator and then the time for the last
operator traction
complete its processing plus any time
that we're going to spend recovering
from failures of course this is subject
to constraints constraints on data rates
consecutive operators do to have
matching data rates constraints on
resource capacity etc and just for those
interested we use a geometric
programming so one component that is
actually difficult to make this happen
is that in order to compute this
function I need to model how the
operators work and that means every time
I come up with a new operator I have to
have new models of how fast they're
going to process their data how they're
going to behave in different failure
scenarios with their different filter
and strategies so for this we actually
developed a technique that allows us to
we only ask an operator writer to
basically specify two functions and one
that is the time it takes to produce an
output double assuming all the data is
in memory and the other function is
simply a mapping of how many output
tuples this operator produces given a
certain number of input doubles that it
received and what we do is we actually
compose these functions together to
figure out that in this setting the
operator will be limited by the input
rate for example or is going to be
limited by its CPU and how the output is
going to look like so the approach that
result is that it's pretty extensible
it's not too difficult to add new
operators the optimization technique
that we use is currently pretty
straightforward we simply enumerate all
the given a query plan our optimizer
uses a brute force approach to enumerate
all the fall trends configurations for
each one it finds the resource
allocation the checkpoint frequencies
that minimize this objective function
and then it picks the plan with the
lowest expected total wrong time so of
course the question now is does this
work a well let me show you some some
graphs of the first questions of course
can our optimizer actually predict how
long the different operators are going
to perform their processing so this is
an example configuration that is pretty
representative of the kind of
predictions that we make this was a
query plan with four operators select
followed by three joints and we
use this 16 machine cluster on the
x-axis here we have different strategies
so either the operators do nothing for
fault tolerance all of them materialize
their output all of them check ponder
States here we have attempts at points
for each operator all we use a hybrid
strategy which was the strategy selected
by our optimizer in this case it was for
the first operator to materialize the
order to to check point and the last one
to do nothing and as you can see we're
not perfect but we do kind of nicely
follow the trend and this is actually to
have very accurate estimates can be
difficult one thing that we actually do
right now to simplify the problem of
this accurate estimation is that we
under 60 machines we actually have 32
disks and we ensure that each operator
partition uses its own disk to write for
writing it's checkpoints writing it data
so you don't have to worry about
sequential vs random i/o because each
operator get sequential I oh that really
simplifies our model it could be
extended for more complex scenarios but
it is kind of one of the challenges to
get these types of reasonably accurate
estimations so the second question is
okay given that we can predict the wrong
times with you know some reasonably good
accuracy well does false parents
optimization matter should we be does it
matter that we do what we do for false
parents so this is actually another
example of a configuration it's exactly
the same query plan we slightly tweaked
the data rates here so that a
metallization was not as on the previous
graph it was basically really losing
compared to the other ones here a little
bit better and what you can see several
things actually interesting in this
graph so here we have the different
strategies starting with what MapReduce
would do which is to kind of write data
out and materialize and block what the
parallel database would do which is just
blindingly fast process the data but if
something crashes restart the query the
other ones are uniform strategies of all
operators do nothing checkpoint
reasonably frequently checkpoint
infrequently materialized their data or
the hybrid in which case the hybrid
selected by our optimizer was too as I
mentioned materialized checkpoint
checkpoint and do nothing and there are
several interesting things on
y axis we have the wrong time for this
query the blue one is the normal run
time without the failure and the red one
is kind of the expected time to recover
from one failure that happens sometime
during the execution so in this specific
configuration MapReduce was really not
the optimal strategy because the
materialization was just adding a huge
overhead to the wrong time but as you
can see recovery from failures was much
faster and what is interesting is
several things first of all if we take
kind of these techniques of
materializing everywhere or doing
nothing but we at the same time
materialized everywhere about pipeline
data through the operators or do nothing
but make the operators individually
recoverable we get into these two
strategies which already help us improve
the total run time the second strategy
that we can see is that our optimizer
may not necessarily pick the best time
here doing nothing this configuration is
a tiny bit faster in the end but still
we can avoid any bad plan so we are
pretty good at selecting good plans even
if you don't necessarily select the
perfect plan because our estimates are
not completely accurate so in summary we
are finding in our experiment that in
different settings different strategies
can be preferred and that we are able to
to find a good strategy often a hybrid
one automatically the savings can be
significant we are seeing thirty forty
percent improvements but that does
depend on the configuration the
challenge that the models do need to be
accurate and this is difficult in
certain inserting scheduling and in
certain settings in our case like I said
for example we ensure that each operator
rights to its own disk to make sure we
can predict the times more accurately
and overall as ed said really well this
morning we have a data deluge people
have lots of data they need help
analyzing processing this data I just
described one example of a project that
we're doing to help them with this but
this is part of our broader new ash
project and i invite you to visit our
website at new Ashdod CS that Washington
that Ed you and finally none of this
would be possible without great sponsors
including Microsoft thank you
okay yeah I was expecting a mic oh yeah
okay if I may I would like formulate two
questions but if there's not enough time
to answer those for help you can take
one more fun so the first is well amazon
ec2 have less than 20 hours of downtime
for a whole years of 2009 what were the
availability of failure rates for the
resources that you pursue in your
experimental setup that's the first
question and the second is I've heard
that you're trying to optimize may
expand my question is whether may expand
really has an impact on the
interactivity of the applications and
widen to the ball so it costs or if you
looked maybe okay so these are the two
questions so let me maybe answer the
second one first because I think it's a
bit more interesting so the question is
that here in our optimizer we optimized
for total run time versus perhaps we
would like to optimize some other
metrics and thus total runtime help with
interactivity so the I know that's
exactly it's partially well depends a
bit what what kind of interactivity if
you want partial results so that you can
progress in your own work then it
doesn't if you want the complete set of
results by the time you move
you want to look at them then that's the
makespan and any options that's what you
are doing is true with our fault current
strategies in our protocol you do get
partial results you do get results
incrementally but within this context of
having this ability to get results
incrementally we minimize the time to
get all the results and you could change
the optimization metric to be something
else to be something else this is kind
of the one we chose to explore because
it kind of gives you the best of both
worlds you both get you want to have the
ability to get results incrementally but
within this you don't want to sacrifice
the total run time because if you would
sacrifice the total run time you could
just pipeline everything and if
something crashes just restart the whole
query so this way we kind of have
benefits from doing this partial
materialization and it would be possible
to explore other costs for example other
optimization functions such as cost
which simply we didn't look at that yet
the explorations base grows
exponentially with each axis that your
advocate pure ethanol so intermediary
results and looking at something else be
writing costs the same that's one of the
problems are interesting so currently we
explore very nave you so our goal was to
simply say is there a point in doing
this fall trends optimization do we gain
anything from it what do we gain and
that's the question we're trying to
answer and once you go past this then of
course yes you would have to be smarter
about the way we explore the space not
explore the entire space in this brute
force manner etc so I know if maybe
someone else
to consider changing the great rarity of
your operators changing by changing the
granularity dooming having just more
operators or more partitions of the same
operator as you're stepping through
you're basically doing in optimization
for college
the MapReduce framework provides from
the National Governors
I guess the question is you're doing it
sort of within the operator disappoint
the operator
you're basically that making your
there's more individual steps in their
operation yes relying more on the
framework lesson custom
so the question is whether we would so
yes so if I take an operator that is a
black box operator I could partition it
into three operators or group these
three operators into one operator but
our framework would do is make that
whatever granularity we choose
individual irrecoverable so this is
similar to MapReduce that whatever is
your operator becomes the unit with
which we can recover from a failure the
advantage of grouping many operators
together is you can kind of send the
data really fast from one operator to
the next because they are grouped
together perhaps running in a single
process the advantage of splitting them
up would be that if any if those are
kind of multiple pieces of a very long
computation you could recover even
throughout that computations I guess
this would be a trade-off in how you can
recover question is at what point does
it make sense to
first is to segregate because
last piece
that works i guess the way we kind of
this bonding comes up in our scenario is
that if it makes sense to bundle some
operators we will likely find that it's
probably worth it to do nothing to
recover a bunch of these operators
except maybe at the boundary and that
might be a hint that these operators
could benefit from being combined
together this is the way it would I
guess you reflect in our framework but
we don't offer this as an option we
didn't explore this as an option myself
so one of the things about failures as
you scale up systems to very much
failures
amazon looks like it's up all the time
it's here the constant
so that your experiments you would like
to look at one failure and thought about
the scalability adaptability as soon as
you get larger density failures that's
right and our friend can handle this so
the greater the density basically takes
care of the probability of failure per
node per time unit if you want as an
input so if the failures are very likely
it's going to favor techniques that do
more fault tolerance because then i want
the granularity of my recovery to be
smaller so do take that as a parameter
in the experiments it's just that it's
kind of easier to show this is the
expected time I mean the total run time
and then the added time for each
recovery so if you fail multiple times
you would add these red blocks on top
and eventually depending on how many
failures occur the strategies that have
smaller recovery times would then start
to win and we take that as a parameter
clearly that's why and it has to be an
input because it depends on the network
network properties so our next talk is
by Paul Watson from the school of
computing science at Newcastle Paul has
been working on some really interesting
problems and using cloud infrastructure
for some time he's a real pioneer in
this in the application space and he has
been working doing some very impressive
stuff with pharmaceutical and chemical
related things and we'll let Paul tell
us more about that okay thanks so so I'm
going to talk about some work that the
Dennis Dennis person we've been doing
with some cancer research scientist at
the National Institute researcher
at Newcastle and when we talked about
what they were they were trying to do it
came down to these two questions that
were really important to them so they do
experiments generate molecules and they
want to know what are the properties of
this of this molecule or they want to
turn that question around and they want
to say well in order to develop a drug
we need a molecule with a particular set
of properties and how can we
how can we do that and the traditional
answer is that well you go to the lab
and you get the test tubes out and you
start to do the start to do the analysis
but of course there's a lot of issues
with this it takes quite a bit of time
to if you've generated a large number of
molecules as a result of your
experiments if there's a costume there's
a high cost in in doing this and of
course there are often ethical issues
because for things like toxicity you
often have to do animal experiments in
order to determine the the results so
the team are working with have been are
looking at alternatives and the main one
is something called Q sauce or
quantitative structure-activity
relationships so the idea here is that
you go and you gather as much
information as you can about molecules
that are in the literature or in
databases were for the molecules you
know what the particular activity you're
interested in is so that you look at a
paper and it says for this molecule the
toxicity is it such and such you gather
all this information together for the
activities that you're interested in
then you're trying to generate these
functions which allow you to predict
based on the structural properties of
those molecules we come across a new
molecule you not seen before what those
properties will will actually be so
that's the idea so then rather than do
the experiment you use these functions
that you've generated in order to do the
prediction this allows you to rule out
lots of molecules that you've generated
which won't have the properties you're
interested in just focus on ten a dozen
that look particularly promising and
then you actually go ahead with the
experiments on those just to validate
that the the predictions are true and
it's quite interesting the way in which
people generally these models so one of
the things that I've noticed in
computing for a while is that some
people have favorite ways of generating
models and it seems quite often there
the pick one when they were doing the
PhD and this stick with it through thick
and thin right right through the whole
career until they they retire and the
chemists of course aren't particular
dogmatic about the models they just want
to get on with the chemistry and so they
were fed up with people saying come
along and saying oh you need to try our
model bone technique it's much better
than the ones that you've already used
so they developed this thing called the
discovery boss and the
this discovery bus is a general-purpose
way of building models competitively so
what they do is they they've got a
database of all the data that they've
collected from publications are from
from debt versus they've got existing
model building tools and this whole set
of the mom mentioned similar things like
linear regression neural networks
decision trees and so on and when they
get some new debt they feed it into this
system and it combines it with the
existing data then it tries all of these
different model generating techniques
one at a time at the moment and then it
compares the results and it just picks
the one which produces the the best
results so they don't care which one it
is and if you come along this is what
I've also put model builders here as an
input if you come along them and say
I've got this new technique also great
we'll put it in our system and we'll
just try it will see whether it's
actually really better than the existing
techniques and if it is you get better
models out of it if it isn't and then
you just discard the the results and
then we've got the scientists who just
want to know that won't be able to
predict the properties of molecules are
at the top there in this diagram and
they're just going to a website of this
website that David Lee he who came up
with a discovery buses team produced it
they're building up and they're putting
all of the results into this website
that they generate so chemists anywhere
could then go and predict the properties
of molecules and if you go a level below
this to have a look at what what's going
on so I'll put this up here because
later on I want to talk about how we
might get some scalability through the
cloud with this with this sort of a with
this discovery bus system then you can
see it various stages so you do the
typical thing where you take the data
for a particular activity you split up
into a training set and a test set for
the training set you work out the
particular descriptors that you're going
to use for prediction so this could be
the could be something the solubility
could be the number of atoms something
simple as that to me could be something
to do with the shape of these molecules
and then you combine these descriptions
in particular ways and then they have to
filter out descriptors because you want
to try and reduce the number of
descriptors you're using because for one
reason the more the script is the longer
it takes to do the learning but the
second reason is that if you can use
fewer descriptors then you
get more generalizable results so the
result you get ants or specifically
tailored to the data that you train it
on they generalize against new molecules
that they aren't in the training set so
they do that and then the fire it offers
I say to all of these different sorts of
sorts of models so there's this for
shown there but there's a few more that
they a use in the system as well and
then they compare the results and pick
the best ones and put those into the
website so that scientists can then can
then use them so that's the basic
structure of the of the discovery boss
and this was all going very well until
there's been a debt so we've heard about
in Ed's excellent talk we've heard about
this data deluge in many areas of
science and it turns out in chemistry as
well as being this deluge of of new data
so they can now go and pick from from
these data sets so you can see the top
one Campbell did around 600,000
different combat compounds and that's
been gleaned from scientific
publications going through things like
one bat worthy for one by PK with it
basically the activities that they put
on the debt based on clinical
measurements and so up for all of these
all of these datasets it says so here's
the molecule here some structure
information about it and this is the
activity so that's the raw material that
they used to feed into the discovery bus
but the great thing about this so the
great thing is that you can then as you
get more dirt you can generate more
models and you can generate better
models because you can produce better a
better fit for the for the models you're
producing but in the end the amount of
debt has killed off their existing
system because when they got access to
this these amounts of debt they did some
back of their BMI calculations and with
their existing system it was going to
take them 5 years to drive this data
through the through the system and
produce it better models and of course
by the time five years was up there'd be
more deer and so and so they never ever
be able to to catch up so this was the
challenge that we've been working on
helped by help by Microsoft to see
whether we could actually use cloud
computing to get this down to a
reasonable amount of time so this is
what for reasons lost in the mists of
time called Project Junior
which microsoft have kind of been
funding for about 18 months now and so
the idea was to use as you to try and
get this done two weeks rather than
rather than years and to make the date
are available through the website you
can see that the website over there so
um trying to speed this up so if you
look at the possibilities for doing that
well for each different activity you
have data for you can process that
information in parallel so that's one
level but also within this within this
workflow you've got these opportunities
and some of them are obvious so you'll
have guessed that you could have tried
all these different model building
techniques individually that's easy as
it turns out you can also calculate
different descriptors in parallel from
the data that you have and the business
about filtering the descriptors as I
said try and reduce them to allow the
results to be more generalizable then
you can also this opportunities for
parallelism in there as well so this is
what we were we were trying to do so the
approach we took was the discovery bus
is quite a complex a quite complex bit
of software the main person who who
wrote it about 10 years ago is no longer
available to to help us do this I guess
that's something that's quite common
with all of these these old codes so
what we decided to do was rather than
throw it all away and try to reimplement
it what we would do would be to try and
take the existing discovery bus just
capture is a set of VMs on Amazon just
to give us some stability and then to
focus on those bits where we thought we
could paralyze it in for those parts we
would then send those parts off to off
to as you in order to do this we used a
solution poly sign central that we base
most of our work on so slight divergence
from the discovery because I'm going to
talk a little bit about e-sign central
so you understand how we're actually
driving the the azure cloud so one of
the things that is always slightly
worried me about whenever there's a new
wave of computing comes along so we
heard it with grids and now with clouds
the people often some people give the
impression that because they've written
the hello world program and it turns out
to be quite easy then all of the
problems of building scalable dependable
distributed systems all magically
disappear whereas actually they they
don't they just move
in fact the first talk in the session
was an excellent example that taking
existing techniques from databases and
moving them into a cloud computing to
solve those those problems and so what
we decided to do is to see well rather
than have people build from scratch
their applications on cloud so ed and
his talk talked about the fact that you
said something like Amazon was there was
the cloud for developers because you
could build everything right from
scratch well you can do that but you
need very good skills if you to really
build scalable distributed systems on
that sort of lower level so we were
trying to think about how we might make
this make this easier so if you look at
this diagram on the left I guess this is
the consequence if you just built on a
low-level cloud infrastructure so you
say it your data but your your design is
your developers there you go you can
have as many CPUs as you want you can
grab all the data storage you want just
get on with it and build your
applications and you end up with them
building from quite a little level and
building the dangers every scientific
application that the build is a silo
it's all built in a bespoke where
there's no sort of commonality in the
way it deals with security or
scalability or how you run tasks and so
and you've got your users at the top
using these applications which probably
all have different sorts of interfaces
and don't in robbery so so we decided to
try an alternative approach where so
I've been running this e science center
at Newcastle since 2001 so after about
six or seven years of developing
software for about a dozen different
sorts of scientists we SAT back and
thought well what are the common things
that you might want in a science
platform for the crowd what is it that's
common across these these projects so we
started to think about building that
sort of system so the idea is that
you've got your your cloud at the bottom
but you've got this cloud science
middleware if you like to think of it
like that it sits above it and so you
then you've just got thin hopefully it
relatively easy to write science
applications that sit on on top of that
and so we rejected the one on the left
and set off for the one on the right and
so the idea is that we've got the
science club platform for developers and
at the top we
cited to tigger software-as-a-service
approach for users so everything through
a web browser was our mantra in
designing this and when we looked at all
of these different projects the four
things that people seem to want to do
was so they took this debt the deluge
that's the the issue and everybody wants
to store the data the one analyze it in
somewhere eventually they want to
automate that analysis when they're
happy that there's a common way to do
something and they want to share best
practice they just want to capture that
and allow you to redo the analysis a
press of a button and finally they won't
have somewhere to share their data in a
controlled we're not make it all
publicly available instantly but do it
with their PhD students and their
collaborators and perhaps eventually
when they've got the paper in nature or
science they might then make it
available to the to the public so we we
designed this platform which tries to
capture these things that we thought
were important so at the bottom you've
got the the raw cloud infrastructure
with the processing and the storage in
the middle we've got work for enactment
which seems to be a good way in these
signs for people to actually automate
analysis we've got ways with people that
upload services and run them in the
cloud we've got social networking as a
basis for collaboration building
communities and sharing we've got
provenance so you can store either
xml-based provenance or tag-based
provenance about your data so you can
search it and find it yes so sorry meted
it that was meted it wasn't in
provenance where everything that happens
in the system is all captured and
recording the log until you can go
whenever you look at some day you can
see exactly how it was generated what
analysis we used to to produce it and
also what anybody is actually done with
that data to analyze it so we built this
we built this system and this is the
version that people get if they if they
log on and use it to the website we try
to capture a web to type in the face for
it so that's the opening page and this
is our our workflow editor so you can
drag services that you might have
created yourself on there from the panel
on the Left build workflows and then you
just lose it you can see there's a run
button in the middle if you click run
then that goes off and runs either on
our service
on our own service or on a cloud so I'll
talk about how that bit of running it on
a cloud works if you're a human and you
run this when you finish your workflow
you can see the the results there but
the way in which we used it for this
particular problem the discovery boss
was that we also have an API so people
can write application see everything you
can do is a human by clicking you can do
through an API so you can upload data
you can run workflows you can retrieve
the results and view them and so we've
got quite a few different sorts of
applications now which package up
particular sort of scientific analyses
through through these these applications
which just sit and talk through this
this API to the rest of the system for
example we've got some for mobile phones
which are just very simple seeing
selects and data you press a button it
uploads it analyzes it using workflow
and then just shows you a graph on on
the phone with the analysis of your
results so we kept the discovery bus on
Amazon at the top there and it then
talks to assign central through this API
where it kicks off work flows which
implement the functions of the discovery
bus to do the analysis of the of the day
and at the bottom as the workflows run
then as your is called to actually do
the grunt work of doing the analysis in
parallel and so they split that up into
a an extra level of detail at the top
left you've got discovery bus in point 1
which is calling the east side sent or
through this API the scientists the
chemists have devised these these
workflows so they get run by the the
commands through the API this generates
tasks to actually run these services
within the workflows and these are then
sent off to as your so the description
of the software that needs to be run
there's links back to the date on which
they run and these go into as you I'll
talk in a minute about what happens in
in Azure they're running as you and then
the results are returned back to assign
central and then go back to the
discovery bus to be put in the databases
and eventually to appear in the cuse our
website so if we if we look at the part
where there's a handoff between each
side
central and Microsoft Azure so this is
what what's happening to the science
central when it gets a task in a
workflow it calls the the web note for
those of you who know about as you
there's web roles and worker roles had
calls a web node which takes in the
tasks puts them in a queue and then the
trick is to have enough in the queue of
sufficient granularity so you increase
the number of workers on the right hand
side and so you can get scalability so
just standard sorts of parallelism from
30 40 50 years I guess people have been
trying to trying to do this and it
returns results throughout your blob
storage which then goes back to east
side sent one so it's quite a simple
system once you get into into as you so
the current state so this is still
working progress we have this this aim
of getting the five years down with dump
a few weeks and we're we're up to a few
tens of weeks at the moment so we're
getting there but we're not when I'm
finished yet we can run on 100 nodes
which were pleased about with reasonable
utilization but we're still trying to
increase that and the trick the problem
is well if you have a if you have a look
at one of these graphs so we generate
these graphs every every day or so to
work at what's going on and it just
shows you that arms arm dolls law still
applies in even in clouds and so what
happens is the parallel is the party
going parallel worked really well and we
get this big high utilization the purple
line at the beginning but then all of
the coordination the comparison results
creates this long tail so we're now
starting to optimize that and move that
into as your as well so that that's so
that speed it up so to summarize then so
um so the discovery bus I've talked
about is this chemistry application but
actually it's quite a general sort of
pattern you can imagine lots of
different applications where you've got
the stuff you want to do when you dare
to arrive so when you've got new model
arrives I was at a conference a few
years ago and in fasta gave a good talk
and he talked about this idea of a data
cauldron where you throw in rules and
you throw in there and you you throwing
services and new date or new rules
appear and this is one particular
pattern which which which matches to
that and it's good for clouds because
it's got
edgewood bursty requirements so there'd
be no point in buying a big cluster for
the discovery bus because what you want
to do is when this more do it appears in
your dataset you run it and you just
shut the system down in your way from
order and then you run it intensively
and after each run you put the date or
in the in the website so the chemists
can actually use it I do i do want to
stress that that clouds don't make it
easier to build these complex scalable
dependable distributed systems it still
as as hard as ever and this is why we
set up on this task of thinking about
well can we abstract out some middleware
which actually makes that easier other
common things which we could just do
once and make available and you see that
in commercial cloud deployments and if
you look at the sorts of things that
that as you is going to have available
the common sort of middleware in there
for business applications then it'd be I
think it's good for us to think about
what are the common sorts of middleware
for science applications let's see if we
can do those once we've we've shown I
think that you know as your is is a good
scalable solution we found it relatively
easy to to pour our applications to this
and run the money even though some of my
java some of the marine are some of the
ring octave people write these rules in
these model building tools they don't
all agree on the same on the same
software which to build it so we've got
a set of software as well as dotnet
software running on idea at the moment
and that hasn't really been a been a
problem for us and as I say the end
result is that we hope that over time
we'll build it more and more of those
results in this open cuse our website
and that's what the chemists are you so
the chemists won't know anything about
the cloud but they'll be able to benefit
from the date that's been generated okay
lots of time so I have a question
regarding the music patterns of the sign
false you
so I'm here is I'm curious about is
added so how does your user or scientist
submit the jobs the computation jobs to
the system and second do you enable any
dynamic scape scape a scaling mechanisms
in the quarter system to adapt to the
computational requirements of the user
James yeah okay so those like those are
good questions so let me let me go back
to to hear so so this is how they the
scientists would create the the work
that they want to run so they on the
left hand side you've got this palette
of services and you can add your own
services to that in a range of languages
dotnet Java are octave and you then just
drag them and create the workflow and
then when you press run then it's up to
us as the people who who manage the
science central system what happens and
initially and still for many of the
tasks that we we actually run those
services when they're when they actually
are executed they just run on our own
service but the thing that we've done
with Azure is now we can also run them
on a clouded in this case as you behind
the scenes that gives us scalability but
the user doesn't know anything anything
about that they just click running it's
up to us how we have we schedule that
and the same is true if you call these
work for us through the API is well
you've got no control over over over
where they run remind me the second
partly question so do you nibble any
dynamically oh yes yes yeah no we have a
we have a person who does that at the
moment so it's quite dynamic but we
would like to we'd like to be able to
automate that we did some work a few
years ago on sort of autonomic computing
where you monitor response times and and
grab more more nodes is appropriate and
that's something that we want to do but
we haven't done it so far
on the computational chemistry side way
back to begin and talking you're talking
about testing different models are you
talking about trying out different force
fields different parameterizations on
those force fields from known data what
what's going on okay so bear in mind I'm
not a chemist so are you a comes yeah oh
yeah okay so um yeah so so as I
understand it that when you get the the
data in the database is more obscene you
get a quantitative measure of activity
for some particular activity like
toxicity say and you get from the
molecule you can derive all sorts of
properties from it about the shape the
number of atoms log P and so on and what
the what the modeling system does is to
take those quantifiable measures of the
structure and try to relate them to the
activity through these models so that's
actually what's what q saris is doing
yes that makes sense
so
pixel okay workflow diagram yeah what a
chemist doesn't find a rock star for a
workflow what okay so freaking what yes
so so you can so at the moment we have a
development environment so you can take
some code in our octave dotnet Java
probably some other things I've
forgotten about and you package it in a
fairly simple way basically just talked
about how you get the day that's coming
into the service and how to get it out
of that that service then you upload it
and it appears as one of those blocks on
the left hand side of the diagram and
then you can use it in in workflows now
we're we're simplifying that at the
moment so that be easier for you just
particular for scripting languages just
to click on a on a new block and dumped
in some some are for example which seems
to be very popular these days with a
scientist that we work with and press
save and then that would be how its quit
but at the moment you do it in a in a
special environment which packages of
the software is process our work will be
interested
the amount of data that actually flows
around the system is relatively small so
it's not a I couldn't give you the exact
results but one of the reasons why it
works reasonably well at the moment is
that the amount of dirt that we send
from me sign central to as you is only a
small number of tens okay now I think
that's one of the interesting things
about about clouds about at what point
you commit and say right i'm just going
to use this cloud because i can't afford
to move my data around dynamically but
we're not there yet at the moment but
i'm sure that will that will come and
then we'll have these hard decisions to
me eventually village province part of
your life yeah given that you work in
such a heterogeneous in Ramat across
amazon and
like some senses yeah you see on this
collection getting more and more complex
and the province wouldn't collect at the
moment is basically everything anybody
does on the system so so when somebody
registered with the system when they
make a social networking connection when
they upload some debt or when they share
it when they analyzed that date will
record the workflows the results that
produce and all the services that that
are run within it I think that and and
that's not actually been very difficult
to collect the hard thing is actually
adding value from it so we've got
there's a panel you can go to and you
can look for any piece of debt at how it
how it was produced and what anybody's
done with it and that's relatively
simple and people seem to like that they
like the way in which you can get some
sort of confidence in how this date was
produced and because everything's in
this one system that can go through
through the web you can go back and have
a look at the workflow that produces
idea or and see if you like it and if
you don't you can change it or replace
it with your own workflow but the thing
that we're the thing we're trying to do
now is to use techniques like
computational intelligence to actually
advise the scientist as they go along so
what I'd like to do is I want flick
through the page but if you looked at
the there's a there's a blank bit of
space on our web page and that's going
to be filling up with adverts as you get
with a traditional commercial their
website that will be filling with things
like well of the people who you are
connected to most people who are working
on this data would actually use this
workflow to analyze it or you know when
somebody goes to workflow you'd then get
advice and say well these are the people
you know I've actually used this
workflow and this is what they've done
wit and then you might you might just go
and have a look or you might pick up the
phone and talk them so I think that's
the interesting part of problems it's
it's actually not collecting it it's how
you can extract as much value from as
possible to help spread best practice
through the system actually how many
active user response right now and where
is also for experienced another our
greatest complaint about the current
system of greatest happiness because
it's you take a great system I'm just
curious about since you actually have
users yeah so we've got 40 to 50 users
although of course see the discovery bus
looks like one user and actually that's
that's run I think we're up to 150,000
work flows through the system in the
last few in the last few months so that
automated users our main use it but
there are 40 to 50 humans as well
running the system the thing so the
thing that surprised me was that we put
an enormous amount of effort into the
workflow and uploading services and when
you go to concerts like this you always
get more questions about that then than
anything else when we actually put it in
front a scientist the thing that they
use most is just the simple social
networking to upload data and to share
their in a controller with their
colleagues and we have it we have a
blogging system which is it's like an
ordinary blogging system but it's under
the same security regime where
everything else so you can you can use
it like a lab notebook or you can share
all your entries are just individual
entries with your supervisor or with
groups of colleagues and so on until you
see people using that and then they'll
say I've got this date I've analyzed it
these are results I got I think it's
this and then somebody else will comment
and say well have you tried this
workflow on it and I've tried this and
so on so actually at the moment that
cloud the basic collaboration tools that
we have because they can take advantage
of of the fact that in the blog's you
can refer to the date with some people
and go back and look at the day and you
can see the workflows which produce that
data they've actually been the most
popular part rather than the only effort
we put into actually generating the
workflow editor on it through it through
a browser which was quite quite tricky
and the word for enactment so in the
connection to the crowd so I'm hoping
they'll be this pipeline that people
start by doing that sort of
collaboration showing and then they'll
gradually move to doing more and more of
their their real grunt work of the
science in in the system
always just oil I in the field and
that's great because they don't they
don't notice a problem with it they just
go directly to the chemistry facebook
that's right instance time for one more
question maybe a yes/no questions three
dances know all right so serve all bonds
all from iit delhi we'll be talking
about some more hard core systems topics
now inside the virtualization layer so
thank you oh yes i mean probably start
changing gears from a previous talk so
my talk is looking inside the
virtualization layer for performance
security and software fault tolerance ok
so as a background to my talk there's a
lot of virtualization software available
in the market and there's a lot of good
butcher oh sorry ok so didn't make any
difference it just really ok ok so
there's a lot of which good
virtualization software available in the
market and the two things that I would
like to point out virtualization
software has become is very much
mainstream today and the use of
virtualization software is growing over
time and I mean assuming with all the
cloud computing paradigms that we
talking about really become a reality of
significantly large percentage of a
software is going to run virtualized so
virtualization layer is really going to
be almost as of equators as an operating
system is today and that that's
interesting for a systems researcher or
from a programming language researcher
point of view because it gives you
another place where he can kind of you
know test your silly ideas and play with
things and that's part of what I'm going
to do in the stock today ok so there i
will divide virtual machine monitors
into three and all very broad categories
depending on how they implement a
virtual machine monitor the first
category of virtual machine monitors is
the ones which use binary translation
this is completely software only
approach where you
translate the code of the guest
application than the OS before you
execute them by giving a delusion that's
actually running on a real machine this
approach was pioneered by VMware in 1998
when they were founded and there are
perhaps the the single biggest
virtualization there that's actually
using this kind of an approach the
second category of virtualized virtual
machine monitors are the ones which use
hardware-assisted virtualization we are
using a hardware support available in
recent processors both by Intel and AMD
and this is by far the most common way
to virtualize workloads and there are
lists of products which are using this
kind of an approach and the third kind
of virtualization platforms is what is
called paravirtualization we are the
idea is that you do not need to export
the exact same abstraction as out of a
real machine in a virtual machine
assuming you could patch or modify the
guest operating system in some way you
could perhaps get better performance or
better consolidation ratios and this was
an idea thus pioneered by Zen so on
somewhere around 2003 so notice that
some of these products are doing or and
more than two places and that's because
they were implementing both those things
okay so while the virtualization
software that be hard today it's pretty
good at what they do there are some
missing features that I'm and that's
what I'm going to talk about today in
the stock one of the things that none of
these virtualization software do is
optimized code so there's been a lot of
work in the compiler community before
virtualization was as mainstream on
dynamically optimizing code right
there's been papers lots of papers and
dynamic optimizers and we feel that a
virtualization layer is a good place to
kind of actually implement those ideas
the two big advantages of doing this at
the virtualization layer one because the
virtualization layer is right at the
bottom of an entire software stack it
has the view of the entire operating
system and its applications as its
optimizing so any optimized association
that you implement there is going to
have a waste much wider effect then
let's say an application-level optimizer
and second is simplicity one of the
reasons why a dynamic code optimizer has
perhaps not seen widespread adoption is
because an optimizer needs to be really
a
air of all the various abstractions and
operating system is extracting and make
sure that it's not breaking any of them
well because a virtual machine monitor
is actually implementing a very small
and unbreakable abstraction of a real
machine the complexity is much more
manageable than you're doing it at the
virtualization okay the other thing that
you can implement in the virtual I
assume machine monitor the security a
virtual machine monitor is a is usually
very small piece of software for example
the monitored via we are developing is
you know less than fifty thousand lines
of code compare that with a typical OS
which will easily run into millions of
lines of code and so because of the
small stack as surface attack area of a
virtualization layer it's a good of
place to kind of enforce your
virtualization for your security
policies now I'm also going to talk
about an interesting idea to be able to
do tolerate some bugs in the software
that a virtualization layer runs above
it okay what I also call software for
tablets okay so what are we doing well
we're developing a virtualization layer
for the x86 platform from grounds up we
decided to do it do it from grounds
because we are making we have kind of
made many design decisions which are
kind of different from what a typical
from what current virtualization
platforms do so well we run an
unmodified OS so we don't end up the
power of virtualization space we can run
an unmodified OS we dynamically
optimized code as it runs and to be able
to do that we use binary translation so
because our objectives are kind of
different we need to use by any
translation and we cannot kind of just
use plain hardware-assisted
virtualization because we are using
binary translation it gives us a very
high degree of control over the system
and we can and allows us to specify
security policies which are enforceable
add instruction level ground already i'm
going to give you an example of that we
can record and replay an execution as
its occurring so we can actually record
an equal in execution while while the
guests software is running it can
install an existing away so one of the
now there's a client virtualization is a
a nice buzz word for some time and one
of the desirables is that can I actually
install a virtualization layer on an
existing system which already has an Oso
installed on it and this is one of the
desirable one one of the features of our
thing and it's transparent to the user
and try to keep it as simple as possible
ok so in picture mode this is a
traditional picture the is the hardware
which has memory disk network artsy
reports and other devices and the OS is
the layer which is in charge of all this
hardware and then the OS is exploiting
certain kind of abstractions on which
the application is written to and it's
running applications this is the
virtualized picture with our virtual
machine monitor the matching machine
monitor basically slides breathe OS now
it is in charge of all the hardware
devices but we don't want to get into
the business of writing device drivers
for all the possible devices in the
world so most of the devices are
actually just passed through devices not
to the OS because they always typically
would have device drivers for these
devices but there are certain devices
that we do need control over because we
need control over the keyboard for
example we need a control over the
console where we are going to display
our stuff and we need control of the
disk where the virtual machine monitor
itself is going to live so those are
perhaps the only three devices that we
really need to emulate or and you should
write device drivers for ok so I'm going
to talk about how we are about the
binary translation layer that throughout
the brain where the binary translator
inside a virtualization layer basically
the way it works is that we divide we as
we are executing code we divide the code
into what we call translation blocks
what is the translation block well
translation block is a snippet of code
which ends at either a control flow
instruction like a direct or indirect
jump for example or when a certain
threshold of my instructions which I
called Max instructions has been
translated okay so simple scheme to
implement a buy new translator is the
following I look at the original code
fragment which is the code fragment from
either the guest operating system or an
application that is running on top of it
I binary translated and produce the
translated code fragment
and then I execute a translated code
fragment and when I get to the end of
the translated code fragment I know what
the next instruction pointer is and I
cannot repeat this process what is the
problem with this well the original code
fragment is going to be typically you
know less than 10 lines of 10
instructions and the binary translator
is going to be lets say around 50,000
instructions on average to do it and you
have a straight away 5,000 x slow down
so if I were to actually use this on a
real operating system it won't boot
across beyond the first hundred
instructions not a good idea an obvious
refinement let me use a cash right so I
the same picture but now when I
translate the code actually save it to a
cache which I call the translation cash
translation cash is being you looked up
using the address of the code in the
original code fragment which is denoted
by the variable X here and this X
because i'm using i'm running below the
operating system is basically the
physical address in the system right so
we are working in the physical address
space now well after every translated
code fragment I first look up the
translation cash to see if I have
already translated a code fragment
earlier and if it's found well well it
good I can just execute it right from
the cash if not I take the bigger step
this is a good improvement if my binary
translator was 50,000 instructions my
look up procedure is you know a hash
table lookup which could be a 5,000
instructions which still is not good
because the 5,000 instruction overhead
for every 10 instructions of the
translated code fragment is a 500 x slow
down ok so we need a better idea we know
the next idea the next idea is direct
jump training we basically say that in
the original code there's likely to be a
lot of direct jumps and so I could use
that information to build in Derek jumps
in the translated code so in this
control flow graph let's say there were
four translation blocks ABC and D which
are linked using direct jumps shown as
in these arrows in the translated world
it would look something like this where
after every execution of a translation
block I would need to do a lookup
procedure right without our direct jump
chain well what i could do is simply
link up all these translated block
fragments to each other exactly as they
were linked in the original quote and I
a better performance at this point
assuming that i only have direct jumps
my performance of my translated code is
very close to native performance because
what i am really doing is executing the
translated code which is likely to be
almost the same size of the original
code and then directly jumping to my
destinations which is very good there
are some subtleties though that you need
to be careful about because here I am
talking about a cache environment right
so in a cache it's possible for things
to get evicted or thrown out so what
happens if one of these translation
blocks now there are dangling pointers
and I need to be careful about removing
all these dynamic pointers so for
example in this case if there is a jump
to be from a it will be looked up again
and so I mean you need to be careful
about something like this okay so that
is direct jumps similar issues exist
with indirect jumps and the most common
form of indirect jump in code especially
for the x86 architecture is that it
function return instruction right so a
simple thing let's say there's a this is
the control flow of the original code
the translation block a calls a function
f function returns and calls be at this
point the call instruction is the direct
jump right so it basically we can do the
same direct jump optimization that I
explained to you in last leg but at this
point i do not know a translation time
what the return address is going to be
right somebody could have to change the
return address so what I need to do is
actually it will pop up the return
address and look up the return address
in my translation cash before I can
actually jump to it assuming my return
happens every hundred instructions in my
code lookup takes five thousand
instructions there's a 50x slow down
there which is not good right so an
optimization let me have some kind of an
cash for the look of function let me
have a faster lookup table which I call
the jump table it is basically an array
which can be indexed using a 10 line
instruct 10 highly optimized 10
instruction assembly code let's say this
is much better because now if I have a
return instruction every hundred
instructions and the overhead on average
is 10 instructions for every day under
instructions that I only have a ten
percent over okay so those are some of
the ideas that we have implemented in a
binary translator I'm going to move
straight away to some of the results
with all these optimizations that I just
described so this graph is basically
giving us some of the good news where I
am kind of using some small to medium
integer programs bub sort is a bubble
sort routine empty loop is a for loop
which is just doing nothing and
computing to a large number these are
kind of pathological cases that we
wanted to study Fibonacci ITER is
computing the first few Fibonacci series
numbers using an I trading method annoy
one Android 203 are three different
algorithms I traded algorithms to solve
the towers of an eye problem and print
if is a routine which is printing random
strings to the console repeatedly ok the
bars are basically showing showing what
are the overheads of a binary translator
the blue bars are the default behavior
with all the optimizations implemented
and the red bars are the behavior when
there was no jump table and I didn't so
I didn't use the jump table so let me
just focus on the blue bars for a moment
I see that my overheads are actually
pretty small which is a good news with
the maximum overhead being around
thirteen percent and in fact in some of
the cases I am finding speed ups so
there are the interesting things that
are going on here because i'm using a
binary translator the cash is smaller
than the actual code and so you know
there are issues with the instruction
cache that are actually helping us in
some other cases it's come something
very interesting another interesting
thing is happening in this benchmark
called printf because i am writing the
console and console is one of the
emulated devices what happens is in in a
native implement in a native execution
the console I of port would be written
to over and over again whereas in an
emulated case a lot of those rights get
buffered and write it into one's giving
us an improvement actually a speed up
over the native Egyptian ok so that's
those are the good news there are some
bad news if there are lots and lots of
function returns there's lots and lots
of function calls and returns the binary
translator is actually doomed ok so here
are some examples of benchmark so Euclid
people reckon near us within is euclid's
computing the greatest common divisor of
two random numbers over and over again
of different numbers febo deck is
basically computing the fibonacci series
again but this time recursively so you
can imagine that there are lots and lots
of function calls are interns and Orosco
tennis is a well-known prime finding the
first end
much is in the sieve method once again
the blue bars are the default behavior
in the red bars are the no jump table
behavior thus overheads are much higher
right hundred fifty-six percent hand
foot in person and these are the
overheads and the reason here is of
course that there are lots of function
returns and function returns are not
well optimized for a binary translator
the reason function returns are so
costly because we are trying to emulate
a function return in exact exactly in
semantics and we could kind of relax
that requirement to get better
performance so this is this is a cause
for concern and we need to kind of solve
it I'm going ahead to be able to have a
really an optimizing VMM salsa okay this
graph shows the advantages of doing
chaining versus knowing not chaining I'm
going to skip this graph okay this slide
shows the effect of the size of the
translation block so recall that my
translation block was chosen either at
the end of one control flow instruction
or when maximum instructions reached
right so the x-axis i basically plot the
value of that max instructions parameter
starting from 1 through 24 and voip I
access I'm again plotting the overhead
so you can see that the overhead is very
high when might each of my translation
block is only one instruction large but
very soon the overhead becomes close to
what the best overhead could be and you
know around nine instructions it
basically saturates the best value which
is which plays well with the comma with
the well-known wisdom that a typical
basic block is usually six to eight
instructions long so default value of
our translation block is 12 instructions
okay this graph basically shows the
effect of the translation cache size so
once again the translation cash is kind
of a parameter that can change the
performance of a way because most of the
benchmarks that we use were small the
trends are actually pretty much clear
one of the benchmarks that I would like
to bring your attention to the printf
benchmarks printf has a lot of code for
example to do the format string parsing
and the device driver for the console
and stuff like that and you can see that
as the translation cash is increasing
the overhead is decreasing that the two
curves are for the two different cache
of placement algorithms namely clue
and random and you know talk is slightly
better than random let's say okay so
what are the optimizations we are
inventing so we're implementing peephole
optimizations where we could replace a
sequence of instructions with the faster
sequence of instructions the nice thing
about a binary translator design is that
the the the input p full translation
table is kind of an input to the
translator and we can kind of keep
pumping in more people translations
which could be either coded in manually
or automatically generated trace
optimizations where we can kind of look
at what is the hottest race in the code
execution and special and emit special
code for that hottest race and then
cross-layer optimizations optimizations
that actually transcend OS boundaries
like the system call boundaries right
which would not which are not actually
possible with either application level
dynamic optimizers and definitely not
possible that static translators so all
this is actually well known stuff just
that we are trying to do it at the
virtualization layer okay here is an
example very quickly of an optimizer of
a peephole translation rules it says
that if there are two loads from the
same memory location to do different
registers let me replace it by the load
and a move this all very well when you
are talking about a word an application
level why new translator but when we are
talking about virtualization after we
talked about the virtualization layer
and you are running an OS on top of us
need to be a little more careful for
example what happens for in an interrupt
what happens if an interrupt occurs
between these two instructions right the
interrupt handler could beam could have
made certain assumptions on how the code
was written for example it could have
made the assumption that are one would
have m44 are 0 or whatever and we want
we do not want to break things in any
way and we cannot make any assumptions
about what the interrupt handler code do
the simple solution to do to handle this
is vinod is even interrupt it could be
timer interrupt disk interrupt any other
device in trough I just delay the
delivery of the inter up to the guests
till to the end of the current
translation similarly exceptions what
happens if there was an exception
somewhere in the middle of a translation
it said as an instruction which gets
translated into a sequence of
instructions and somewhere here after
updated a certain state there is a page
fault right now the page fault handler
could have made let us say an assumption
over what the stack pointer value could
be and to be able to do this properly I
need to have some sort of a rollback
code so these are just some subtleties
one need to be careful about when you're
doing a binary translator at the
virtualization there ok so I'll change
so the advantage of doing a binary
translator is I mean the primary
advantage I feel doing a bank translator
is that there's a lot of flexibility and
lot of control over what you could do so
here is an example of how you could know
words what how simple it would be to
kind of implement a security policy
let's say I want to implement a security
policy which prevents all stack overflow
buffer overflow attacks well the simple
thing could do would be to have a shadow
stack in your virtualization layer and
say that apart from all the other code
that I am generating for the coil
instruction let me another instruction
in my binary translator which basically
pushes the return address to the shadow
stack and the return instruction now
apart from lying all the other stuff
that I was doing also does the following
which means it pops the shadow stack and
checks it against the real stacks value
to see if they agree or not they so
night I mean a simple way to kind of
implement a security policy transfer is
transparent to everything else okay a
similar thing you could do I mean
similarly because you're doing a binary
translator implementing something like a
record and replay is very simple all I
need to do is capture all the non
determinism in this in the guests now
non determinism is due to either i 0 or
interrupts and I can kind of write these
rules very easily to log all these
events whenever they happen in our
binary translator ok so here's the table
of what how much are slow down it takes
to implement a record replay mechanism
well these numbers are not really
flattering there's I'm showing a 200 x 2
500 x slow down and compute intensive
applications and the 7x slow down an i/o
intensive application but this is mainly
because you know when I mean when I'm
kind of logging an interrupt I need to
log exactly what is the number
what is the instruction boundary at
which I got this interrupt and to be
able to give this count of instructions
I need to have you know an instruction
for instruction to kind of increment the
how many instructions are executed there
is the smarter ways to do this for
example I could use harder performance
counter and this is something we are
working on but just to give you a flavor
of what it takes to do a record replay
in conclusion we think the
virtualization layer is a good place to
do many interesting things and we are
excited by this opportunity a question
we are asking is can we make the virtual
machine appear well a virtual machine
actually looks like completely I could
roil machine but can it appear faster
than a real machine and in what
situations more secure and more reliable
look thank you
I wasn't sure when you would delay the
interrupt you later on yellow on your
your example by warning system that
simply because you had this idea that
that was said fine that's what
instruction but how did you know how how
long you have to delay i didn't come
together than ever say okay that's
basically at the translation boundary so
if i receive an interrupt I kind of see
where did I see the interim and I have
some kind of a data structure which says
that this original translation is he
this original source code corresponds to
this translated code and so I have these
boundary points at which it's safe to
take interrupts and anywhere in the
middle it's not safe to take interrupts
I can kind of maintain this data
structure and that's what we do the
optimization should move are normally
the same across different underlying
practices
why ya say so the nice thing is that we
are not sitting on top of an operating
system we are sitting on below the
operating system right so all my
experiments here are basically based on
an undergraduate operating system called
pintos but what we want to do initially
is to be able to run a full operating
system like either windows or linux and
be able to kind of see what if X beta we
are not dependent on operating system
only because we are we kind of running
directly over hardware and kind of
passing through all the devices Oh will
I need to do different types of
optimizations well yes I mean the only
answer I can the best answer would be
only after i had do the experiments okay
thank you oh sorry